hey guys happy holidays to you and if
you're still uncertain about a gift to
get someone else or more importantly
yourself like I happen to do you know
I'll go in the Best Buy to get a dang
record player you know from my and I'll
come out with you know two microwaves
for myself and just do microwave races
at the house and see which one can you
know put more heat into a dang taquito
but what I'm saying is this it's that
time of year where you can still get a
gift for somebody and it's okay and one
of those things you can give somebody is
an audible membership audible have an
access to an unbeatable selection of
audio books including bestsellers
motivation mysteries thrillers memoirs
and more with an audible membership you
can choose three titles every month one
audiobook and two audible originals that
you can't hear anywhere else what I'm
currently listening to on audible is out
of the shadows understanding sexual
addiction by Patrick Carnes and he's a
PhD and right now for our listeners and
for a limited time you can get three
months of audible for just $6.95 a month
that's more than half off the regular
price that's right three months of
audible for 695 a month more than half
off the regular price support this wet
this past weekend give somebody the gift
of of Education of information it's a
wonderful way to listen to read with
your ears go to audible.com slash Theo
th EO that's audible AUD IB le dot-com
slash Theo and happy Holidays to you and
yours today's episode is brought to you
by gray block pizza gray block pizza
18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on
the way to the beach there have been
moments in my life where my mouth was
empty and then I realized there's a way
I can change that gray block pizza get
that hitter today's episode is a very
unique guest this man is ran across more
of the dark arts then maybe anyone he's
come face-to-face with them he's he sat
them down you know I'm from to catch a
predator you know him from his years of
investigative journalism he is something
unique let's get to know him right now
ladies and gentlemen it is mr. Chris
Hansen
[Music]
thank you for joining us today my
pleasure thanks for happening yeah and
have you do you get out to Hollywood a
lot I do because some of the production
companies with which I work are based
out here mhm so when I was doing the
crime watch Daily Show for instance
that's Warner Brothers there you know
right there in the Burbank area right
and so I get out here frequently do you
do on a crime is so people are obsessed
with crime they really are I mean you
look at the show for instance killer
instinct that is on Investigation
Discovery the ID Network and that
network literally has either the first
or second number of female viewers from
that coveted demographic yeah not just
of cable but in all of broadcast right
and people watch because it went and
because females are those are the ones
most likely to be like shopping and
spending money with advertising right
well I taken care of hi it's a part of
it we also get a very healthy you know
male viewership on you know the various
crime shows that I do I think what draws
people in is this attitude that I try to
bring to every show where you know I
take the viewer long on a journey of
discovery we get to see things they
wouldn't normally see here things they
wouldn't normally hear yeah you know I
get to go places mm-hmm that most people
don't get to go I get to talk to people
yes people don't get to talk to you and
so that's fascinating for the average
viewer right yeah it's kind of almost I
wonder if you seemed to me like as
because I would consider myself a I
guess basically like this I would
consider myself probably a female viewer
I mean I've watched so much of those
types of programming I mean not really
but I mean it's almost like yeah I guess
I'm almost hidden in that demographic
but you are you're almost like a li
eight li you're like I can't tell
sometimes if I'm like you're you seem
like an Edgar Allen Poe of sorts you
know or like a um like a concierge to
like the dark arts or something a little
bit I mean I know you're reporting and
you're sure you're that you're kind of
the the Sherpa but um well that's valid
you look at some of the different
investigations we've done over the
and yeah I do you know occupy a unique
space in television yeah and journalism
and it's been crime and I've been at it
literally for some 36 years yeah I
started very young in the business I was
six but uh but you know so it's true you
know I was at a a news conference in LA
one time for kicking off a show and one
of the print writers who covers
broadcast for Gannett who has covered me
for many many years so do you ever go to
therapy or get counseling for all the
dark stuff you you do and see you know
it's all kept down there nice and safe
where I like it I'm good do you do you
ever think that those types of things
like that subconsciously though that
interacting with you know such a dark
you know of Voldemort II cauldron of the
universe kind of that that can impact
you like on a level that you're not able
to I think so I mean you look at people
sometimes like what's that guy up to
over there what's he doing over there or
you think through scenarios where
something bad happens and you have to
react not just as a journalist and
covering it but you're in the middle of
it right and it's been interesting
because my two sons are in the business
mm-hmm so one is a assistant cameraman
and production assistant on my shows and
many many others and the others a
reporter and Traverse City Michigan he
just got a job in Oklahoma City oh nice
so you know they've grown up in this
yeah and and you see it affect them a
little bit you know we finished a season
of killer instinct and my oldest son
looks helped me he goes man I am just
murdered out I got food yeah I need to
focus on a flea market flip or something
[Laughter]
gotta go see mr. Ramsay um when you go
back to going back to talking about how
women watch a lot of those types of
shows do you feel like there's something
secretive in women or something that
like I've always had this weird idea
that some women like want to be murdered
in a weird way and I know that's kind of
a drastic statement but like there's
something about it what is that well you
know that's that's a great question
and I think it's it's a lot of things I
think that you know women empathize with
victims and then do too right get a lot
of you know grizzled male cops who watch
these shows all the time and Wall Street
guys and businesspeople and you know all
80 Canadian city code and but I but I do
think that for whatever reason again our
key demographic on a lot of these shows
excuse female you think killers seemed
like tall dark and handsome in a way to
women like is there is there were like
on out like a different level do you
feel like there's some romantic thing
because yeah for some reason in my head
I'm like women secretly all want to have
someone break into their home or
something I don't buy that I think it's
it's more of or I'm gonna learn how this
stuff happens so I don't become a
villain enough and that's kind of the
way I look at these shows these
investigations is if we can hear the
voice of a victim or victim's family if
we can get into the mind of a criminal
whether it's a killer or a predator you
know sex trafficker human trafficker or
somebody dealing heroin and in Dayton
Ohio mm-hmm you can better understand
how it all works and you can prevent
other people from falling into that trap
of becoming a victim themselves and
that's a big part of what I do yeah do
you feel like you know after um like to
catch a predator and you know that do
you feel did you feel like a hero like
at certain points during that show like
did you feel how did you feel like as
that show went on and you guys were you
know you guys were catching I guess I
don't have their pedophiles or perverts
at that point or what the editor I think
is the right term I mean pedophile has a
very distinct definition in psychiatric
circles people use it all the time it
was in the New York Post today and the
flight here yeah so you know people use
that but it the predator is the best way
to put it and and when we first did the
those investigations the first one was
in Long Island and I remember driving
out there thinking jeez what if nobody
shows up what if I've just wasted
thousands and thousands of dollars of
the net
which money and within seconds of that
thought my producer was on the cell
phone saying where the heck are you we
got two guys coming in 45 minutes and he
call the 17 guys show up in the course
of three days including a New York City
firefighter and sort of others and you
can imagine that first investigation I
mean we had security and we had
precautions and we had the online decoys
in the house right and we had it all set
up but we didn't really know how this is
gonna go down so I've got transcripts
all over a dining room table in the next
room and I walk out to confront the
third guy comes in and I'm just trying
to keep my heart in my chest at this
point so you are actually nervous and
you walk out there I was especially in
the first one now you're always are on
edge cuz you don't know what you don't
know right you don't know what is in his
pocket I mean we take precautions we
know the background we know if they've
got our concealed weapons permit and
many other things that we do have as
much Intel as you can but you research
but you know I walk out there when I
confront this third guy in the first
investigation I said it says right here
you want to do this that and the other
thing to a 13 year old girl named Susan
no that's not me excuse me go back get
the other day what about a 14 year old
named Beth no that's not me actually
come back you know a 12 year old named
Betty yeah that's me okay good we can
start you know and it's just it was
there was that much that was just you
know obviously we refined it as we went
along in the most recent investigation
but literally you were like saying oh
the oh sorry transcript yeah I got the
wrong restaurant get the one so you know
we refined it over over time and you
know we the most recent one we did we
now call it Hanson versus Predator and
we ready to do another one very soon and
you know we have it down to a system but
there's always that unexpected
possibility you know again we have
security the police are doing a parallel
investigation so I feel very safe the
crew is very safe but there are a lot of
moving parts here and we essentially set
up a television production studio in
another part of the house because you
know most of what we get in terms of
video is with hidden cameras yeah yeah
I'm seeing that and I'm seeing the
lights kind of hidden like I've worked
with Howie Mandel and some hidden camera
shows so like even when I'm able to
watch some of you guys's work it's like
you know me but even able to see some of
the just the same parallels you know
because a lot of the production kind of
stuff is the same
did you win these guys like did you feel
like as a viewer sometimes when I would
watch that show sometimes I would feel
like remorse I would feel like anger you
know I feel sorry sometimes for the
person that was getting captured not
that like in one part of me if you asked
me any day of the week like what do you
think about you know people that skills
or something yes I would say you know
they'd be damned yeah you know like but
but in that moment in watching it
sometimes I felt bad for them what is
that well sometimes I'm the prosecutor
the detective sometimes I'm the
psychologist just trying to get in their
heads and have them talk to me and
sometimes I'm the the dad you know when
it's a younger guy yeah and I do
sometimes feel empathy for some of these
characters and everybody wants in in our
society one size fits all this is how we
treat the problem yeah and the reality
is that you know not all these guys are
the same character they're the hardcore
you know guys who would go after kids no
matter what yes guys our coach at the
playground with or without the Internet
the middle section is our guys who do
this because they have the access to the
Internet the 24-hour access yeah
anonymity and in just the ability to be
on there and continually chase their
fantasy and all of a sudden they cross
this line between fantasy and reality
and they're knocking on our door and
they're there and then you've got the
younger guys who may be socially inept
and I'm not defending them one bit but
these are guys who you know made a
mistake and they can probably get
probation for a year right and computer
monitoring and they'll get scared
straight yeah I saw there was some guys
gotta get in there 19 19 and 20 year old
you know we usually don't even the
decoys don't even engage somebody unless
they're 21 unless there's a extenuating
circum right so you guys so at a certain
point the decoys started to really seek
out like oh these guys are a lot more
predatory than maybe some young he's
some guy who's 18 years old might be
just a little bit more on the
verted friends or something well we
don't see them out right we have a very
strict protocol okay so the online decoy
will go into various social platforms
and they'll create a profile that is
unmistakeably of an underage child right
picture age of eating there and they
don't contact anybody they get contacted
and then the alleged predator has to
make the sexual suggestion first
otherwise we don't engage
we don't go on say okay here's a 44
year-old man let's see what he's gonna
do if he's approached by a mature
looking 13 year old girl yeah that
doesn't happen
yeah then it's a gray area what we do is
you know pretty much black and white
yeah was there ever a predator that came
in that brought tears to your eyes that
like that you that really like hit you
like there was not because I was sorry
for them but I remember one you know
people always ask what's the most
memorable moment I said well to you know
a hundred away tie for first because
they're all never long but I there was a
fellow in Fort Myers Florida who showed
up to me at 13 or 14 year old boy
clearly had solicited this boy for sex
mmm and he shows up and he pulls up in
an SUV and we're watching on the
monitors and he goes round to the the
passenger side rear door and we think
he's gonna pull out pizza or DVDs or
something the red SUV I think it was it
was blueish green sorry yeah yeah he
they're a bloody yeah to go around so
anyway he gets his five-year-old son on
and then card of the child's seat and
they walk up the driveway and I'm like
how am I gonna handle this one but where
does that hit you does that hit you at
that moment it hits you just as a
reporter like how I'm gonna like I like
Alan oh he took the breath out of the
room now these guys yeah that's a who I
work with I mean I've had him around the
world we've been in Africa and India and
Cambodia on all kinds of heavy-duty
investigations over the years in these
guys we're silent hmm some in tears and
so he walks even when hear you say they
just he's got a five-year-old kid with
him and I don't think he was gonna
involve
the kid in the sex hack she was gonna
put a Barney DVD on in the next room or
you know some some child show and he
walks in and I said look I'm Chris
Hanson you know why you're here I know I
are I'm not gonna subject your child to
what I normally do and he left in a
female officer scooped up the child up
and he was arrested and all the while
his wife's at work on a Sunday yeah in a
retail store and he's running around
town doing this yeah and it's a it's a
lot of that type of behavior it seems
like you know I'm like in recovery and
stuff I guess I'm in a lot of world
where you see a lot of people who
struggle with stuff and they try to get
through their demons I've actually met
friends I have a four now that's a
flasher you know which is crazy right
it's crazy but it's also he's a regular
guy and he has this compulsivity right
that like he's like sometimes I'll go
walking my dog and halfway down the
block I realize I don't have my dog you
know right like so you like start to see
some of the stuff that goes on in his
head right do you feel like a lot of
these guys that that are predators did
something happen to them like where are
you able to see any of that like or
learn about any of that like lineage is
there any lineage I think there's been
some linkage there you know among some
of the 300 plus guys who have surfaced
in our investigations it's hard to tell
because once you know they're off our
radar there are either in prison or in
counseling or doing whatever I think a
lot of it is really just the opportunity
in yeah and in the ability of these guys
to reach out to underage yes I mean
remember when we first started doing
these investigations we merely use chat
rooms on Yahoo and AOL right and that
was just a little box just if that was
it I mean I remember one time when Yahoo
lost all power because of a fire mm-hmm
on the west coast and we were down we
were done we couldn't put our decoys out
there and we couldn't communicate with
the alleged predator and we actually had
to stop the investigation but if you
still came back out so that just shows
you how the Internet is integral and
look at today with Badou and kick and
all these other you know social
platforms with all these things work all
of it that children interacting with vit
on video games with people that they
don't know one of my producers was
having a conversation with with his
teenage son I want to say he was like 14
15 at the time and he said what's that
on your cell phone because all whether
this app where you can randomly talk to
people who are just on the app and he
said well show me how it works
ain't dial somebody up and it's a it's a
42 year old woman who says or someone
who identifies themselves a 42 year old
woman says I'm just jumping in the
shower I'll call you when I get a towel
around me you know he's like no no no no
we're getting rid of that app run out
you know but just without even trying
it's such a gateway it was a random you
know connection do you feel then like
that there's some like sometimes the
Internet I mean even for myself like
I've struggled with in my life with like
relationships commitment I think a lot
of it is probably from or some of it
some of us things have been from growing
up issues ahead some of them though I've
struggled with watching pornography
growing up and like using that as like
an outlet to feel something good about
myself sometimes you know whatever wrong
way that is right but but I can see how
that web can get tricky and you can get
down that staircase and it's excessing
it's a devil yeah it's addictive it's
like it's like an opiate should there be
laws or more restrictions against that
well it's hard to make laws because the
whole notion of the Internet is its
ubiquitous nature and and you know all
the the access is right there I mean I
think there's a responsibility for
parents to regulate children on the
internet I always say that you know the
golden rule should be that if you don't
know the person in real life you
shouldn't be chatting with them or
giving personal information to them on
the internet because the person who is a
stranger on Tuesday can groom kids into
being their best buddy by Friday
yeah it's very dangerous you know it's
interesting
to do this thing called crank texting
right Chris where I would basically take
I took my phone number one day and I
changed the last two digits of it and I
just sent out a random text to that
number and I said hello
right so my last name my name number
ends in six seven so I changed it to
like seven four right and I just said
hello and sent a message out and then
somebody texted me back and like hey
who's this and I was like oh it's Alan
made up a name and that person's like Oh
Alan from so-and-so and now I said yup
and next thing you know they thought I
was Alan so then for a while I started
doing this thing where I was just crank
texting like masses of numbers I would
send like a hey what's up to like large
groups of anonymous cell phone numbers
that I didn't know and one time I found
myself texting it was some kid who's
like after school or something thought
they're in like a band or something at
school and they thought I was some
friend of theirs who was in the band
right and I realized holy this is crazy
like I'm just here goofing around I
trying to like do like prank calls but
on text and next thing you know I'm
communicating with a kid who thinks I'm
immediately appear of theirs
you know they assume it's you know I
obviously I do a lot of social media for
the shows and for what I do for a living
and and you know the vast majority of
the people on Facebook or Instagram or
Twitter they maybe listens but I
actually don't know that right and it's
shocking sometimes what people will
expect from you will say to you and you
really don't know sometimes do I respond
to that if somebody identifies
themselves as a live-in nanny in
Washington State who suspects the
mother's boyfriend has you know improper
interest in the daughter G babysitting
what do I do about that
you know it's a real quandary right no I
that could come into your city happened
last week and this is why you know I get
these every day and so is it a prank is
it real what is my social responsibility
to deal with it you know normally I
alert the police or I tell the person to
alert the police and if they have a
problem with that I will facilitate it
but if I give them advising to go
sideways right are you um
my house in liability or you know how do
I know that somebody's not trying to set
a guy up right
you know you always assume the worst
when somebody reports that sort of thing
but you never know and you don't even
know what that person is who they say
they are yeah
yes somebody could screenshot that and
say Chris Hanson said my husband is a
sexual predator luleå and so you try to
do the socially responsible thing the
journalistically responsible thing but
you have this gray area where wait a
minute
Who am I Who am I actually told you or
you know someone to say hey can you talk
for a minute well I'm an airplane oh I
can't you know and I try to be right I
try to be a - it's hard in all this
stuff and in answer all the questions
and to be helpful but it's it's it's
difficult to follow and again you really
don't know all these people yeah and
you're kind of a lynchpin in a strange
way because a lot of reporters and a lot
of journalists and investigative
journalists you know they have the it
doesn't have their thing that hasn't hit
home and so with so many you know it
hasn't I don't know you have yeah you're
like that you're like the person that
people think of when they think of
anything in that world you know like I
thought of John Walsh and I thought of
you like I mean you know like just in in
terms of like you know just like helping
out children are dealing with issues
with children you know well it's really
hit home with people for a lot of
different reasons you know I only
half-jokingly
tell the story of being parodied on
South Park yeah some years yeah and my
kids were both in high school at the
time and it was the only South Park that
season they didn't see for some reason
they went to bed early and I didn't know
it was gonna be on so I get a call from
one of my agents on the East Coast
saying South Park is doing it right now
it's pretty funny and then about 20
minutes later it's taken a darker turn
when I was a boy so I didn't see it till
you know three hours later and it's fine
look they're right million guys and
there I also use a lot of people to just
gets online and they look yeah it was
dark what I have written it that way no
but I'm not a comedian yeah
you or you know Matt Groening or those
guys right no the stone and Parker dude
yeah yeah in their genius they really
are now you can take issue with whether
it's appropriate or whether you know you
like it or not but in my son's eyes at
you know 16 and 18 years old at the time
or whatever you know that was yeah I had
made it write a book because Chris
Hanson well that's cool now oh yeah yeah
and all the kids it's high school
actually a really bad one so yeah so
that was you know that was the benchmark
but you know it hits home with a lot of
people in look it's very serious subject
matter right it's a very serious crime
at the end of the day just like any
other investigation we're trying to
educate create a dialogue that didn't
exist before and awareness that didn't
exist before
yeah and we've done that we will
continue to do it and and the big lesson
I think is that you know enterprise
journalism is still very important using
techniques like hidden cameras and and
computer aided reporting and things like
that you know you're you really can make
a difference but you've got to get
inside the crime right and it's
sometimes difficult it's sometimes
expensive it's sometimes dangerous and
you have to get you know the network to
buy off on it was there a lot of
pushback when was there a lot of
pushback when you guys first pushed to
catch a predator was there there wasn't
pushback but there was an issue where
some of the people didn't get how to
promote it and I had a very blunt
meeting with with higher-ups in the in
the chain of command and I put it this
way I said there's a man knocking on
your backdoor who wants to have sex with
you thirty no daughter tonight we're
going to show you how to keep that from
happening
and suddenly it was on TV yeah was there
parts were so as it cuz I mean that it
was like a it was like being on the
endeavour you know I mean does that that
show that it was like a spaceship I
don't that's not the one that blew up is
it I hope not the Challenger okay good
yeah so it was like being on the
endeavour I mean that thing was a rocket
right right did
was there parts though where it started
to become too much like okay let's Chris
we want you to talk to a more we want to
watch this guy fry out there kind of
stuff like I think the goal has always
been to get inside these guys minds
whether it's this or whether it's
somebody who is you know trafficking
young women and you're in Los Angeles
runner Atlanta and look anybody can jump
out of the bushes and create you know
ten seconds of dramatic video right my
goal is to get the guy to have a seat
and to explain what brought him into
this situation and more often than not
they will sit and talk now they may run
their line of BS and say I was here to
check on the garage we're worried about
her safety or I was just gonna you know
be a mentor to this young boy and and
and I've heard all the excuses that you
can possibly imagine
but you know I want to know yeah and
oftentimes these guys will open up and
say you know I I just had corn on the
internet and as I got older the people I
was talking to got younger and I just
had this fantasy and you know it seemed
like was you're gonna be okay I mean
I've had guys in the latest
investigation that aired you know last
year is this true crime tale is that a
so this is a part of crime watches so we
did Hanson versus Predator yeah I was
watching and you know we had a guy show
up an insurance executive from Boston
drove all the way to Fairfield
Connecticut brought pizza offered me
pizza offered the crew pizza but he had
in his car a quote-unquote marriage
contract that he thought would make it
legal yes
for him to have sex with I saw him in
he's at an eight Pizza 18 he had the
contract yeah we hit a guy show up who
was an employee of one of the cable
companies who was on the waiting list to
become a police officer in Connecticut
who when they searched his car they
found a loaded gun
duct tape mm-hmm a camera and a knife
oh that's hide-and-go-seek in in
Afghanistan I feel like right but um but
ya know that's that's um I mean that's
scary what's he gonna do with a 13 year
old girl once she goes for a ride with
him right to give quote-unquote a
drowning lesson right yeah what if some
wood at the yes a in one behavior right
right a sex act occurs then he still has
these wet like
what is it then where does his mind go
that he doesn't even know his mind is
about to go right another place where
they know it said what if she you know
says hey wait this is too much for me
I'm only 13 yeah and he kills her yeah
anything happen did did you it's
interesting to me that like when it goes
from online to real life like that's
really a lot of what I feel like when
I'm watching you're like that's what I
started to see like oh this is wild
because this is something that you know
it's this fictional universe online it's
I mean it's real but it's you know it's
not it's not tangible right you know
it's so your brain can go to kind of
dark places but not really be doing dark
things what happens I think sometimes
you hit it right on the head is that men
will say things online that they
wouldn't say face-to-face not to a woman
right shortly not to a 13 year old or 12
year old girl
yeah I'll even text things when I'm
dating somebody that I wouldn't probably
know you think about it later in sales
and say well you know that's not you
know kosher right it's just but I think
people get ahead of themselves yes
sexting or online it feels safer it
feels right it's you're one step removed
and it feels safer and suddenly this
line gets blurred you know at some point
between fantasy and reality and that's
what these guys step over and as I said
earlier come knocking on our door to
fulfill this this fantasy that's
building inside them did you ever feel
so what were you the executive are you
the one calling your own shots as well
as were you directing yourself there was
a whole team would you go into a job
viously we have a right there's a juicer
and we have the crew and we have
security and everything but you know
generally you know I'm out there without
a net we did try one time having a an
earbud so I could communicate it I
honestly didn't like it because it was I
don't when I'm out there whether it's on
those investigations or others and if
I'm listening to somebody I'm not
thinking about what I'm gonna do next
it's like it's like running an interview
like this and having a list of questions
and going from this to that the first
thing I do when it
your hands Melissa questions I put them
on the chair right or you hold these and
when I finish if there's anything else
you want me to do other than what I've
done right because an interview as you
know because you do them you know every
week I'm learning yeah his is is getting
inside somebody's mind and it's more
about listening than looking down at the
legal pad for yeah question well
especially these days I think audiences
want more authenticity I think audiences
feel like they've been so and I feel
like they have it became such a pattern
with television to create like you know
such a specificity
you know fuel by advertising kind of
thing you know like just a bad it just
became water formulaic
yes formulaic and this is this is why I
think I think this investigation and
others like it have become so popular
with people is because you don't know I
don't know what's gonna happen next I
mean I always say a good interview is
when I look back at the producer I say
anything else and he or she says no and
I'm drained yeah you know whether it's
with somebody who almost became a murder
victim somebody who is a relative of
murder victim somebody who's a detective
who investigated a murder or any of
these other cases that we delve so
deeply into do you would did you did you
ever follow up personally with any of
those people like was there ever is it
always like a work does it always feel
like a work kind of are you able
wherever any were you like you know I
need to I need to follow up with this I
think it'd be interesting to go back and
see what some of these guys are up to
and then we're talking right now about
doing that yeah and I think some would
do it I think somebody would say you
know you put me on TV doing something
bad I never want to hear from you again
I hate you you know there are people
posing as some of the Predators caught
in the stings you know on social media
and online reaching out and I have a
hard time when I think it's actually
them right I think it's somebody's sick
prank but I think that would be worth
doing because I think they're gonna be
guys who are angry and didn't change I
think they're going to be guys who
repeat offenders and we know this yeah
and I think they're gonna be guys who
say
you know I've had some therapy I figured
this out I had some time to think about
it and it's it's wrong and they're
probably not gonna reoffending you know
you need to talk to the psychiatrist who
interview them in the prison where they
have no reason to not tell the truth
two things are common one is if they've
done it once they've done it at least a
handful of times and two is there's a
very strong correlation between the
viewing of child pornography and the
commission of solicitation of it Wow
almost always do you think we are able
as humans especially like especially as
men to be able to withstand the the fire
that is coming off the internet like the
internet and social media like are we
even built to be able to I think so I
mean at the end of the day you're just
as responsible online as you are in
person right but instead of rent it is
different clearly as we've discussed but
I still say that you know in this case
you know right is right and wrong is
wrong right I don't care what people are
doing if they're adults and it's
consensual online right that's not my
business I'm not the moral arbiter of
society but you can clearly say that
soliciting a child online yeah and I am
illegal yeah and and wrong on every
level and you create a victim there at a
very young age we scarred for life do
you feel under bleah do you feel though
that that like the it like I guess like
there's I just feel sometimes like it's
hard to battle against not against the
child pornography type of stuff but even
if you just start with pornography right
like it's hard to like it's such a it's
such an opiate in a way you know it's
it's addictive there's no question it
just feels like it's unfair sometimes
like when I think about the young men
now you know like I didn't have as much
access like when I was young we had you
when I was young we had a guy that would
draw a picture of a woman for us for the
weekend if we wanted like if I wanted to
see like some genitalia somehow they had
this guy Nick would draw pictures do you
buy it from him
couple dollar you know I'm of the age
where you know we buried Playboy
magazines in the woods and that was that
was a mom and it was it was it was you
know not even that reishi by today's
date yeah it just makes you wonder like
if kids see that or young people see
that then do other darker things seem
less you know what the the those aren't
real to them you know like just just the
effects of that and us not knowing I
think there are studies that that will
prove that's true that you know the
repeated viewing of pornography and
child pornography especially oh yeah it
is addictive and it creates addictive
you know illegal antisocial behavior and
the anti-socialist has a lot to do with
the to writing that feeds into the
internet so I mean who needs play more
magazine anymore when you can go to
Google yeah and find out whatever you
want
I have blockers on my phone and computer
I'm not for any child so I've never had
you but just from pornography like I
don't want that influence anymore well
you you know you get a friend request on
social media yeah and it can have
breasts in the picture it's just like
delete delete delete delete and you
don't know what what's up or whether
it's real or somebody's creating
something or somebody wants to create a
linkage that doesn't exist but you see
it yeah how many women reach out to
Chris Hanson because like there must be
like a wild web of ladies out there that
are intrigued by you know kind of this
Clint Eastwood of pedophiles kind of you
know it's pretty tame really to be
honest I mean you know there are some
texts like that or messages in social
media like that but generally like you
know 95% of them either
you know whack jobs right ooh you know
something absolutely outrageous like you
know you should burn in hell for what
you do to these innocent men you know
it's like come on it's not even worth
responding to it's block block block and
you know move on and most of its like
we've got a situation a neighborhood
what I do or thank you for what you do
or you should look into this or you know
City Councilmember and whatever city is
is up to no good you know it's it
it's mostly story-related right or it's
my mom you know putting out pictures of
you know my nieces or you know it's it's
it's mostly on brain kind of stuff yeah
yeah there's nothing really yeah but do
you feel like though that there's a I
mean I feel like a you know especially
with so many women watching that type of
programming that they would see you as
like you know you're kind of like a Hugh
a like not that you're a Hugh Hefner but
they would envision you like that well I
mean I think some people have fun with
you know graphics oh oh yeah and all
that yeah body or with that there is one
the other day and I said it to my
significant other with you know I was in
like all built up muscles definitely the
peloton bikes been working for me yep it
feel pretty did you um you know a lot of
people when they think about you know
you guys show there's a lot of tickets
or predator and some of that work and
crime watch daily right it's like okay
that people talk about entrapment a lot
you know that that word gets thrown
around a lot did you feel like that
something no and here's why
first of all you have to be in law
enforcement right to commit entrapment
and second of all we don't create a
situation where we go out and say hey
here's the enticement here's the shiny
red apple come get it these people all
come to us right you know we are passive
we just exist online and the potential
predator has to make that first approach
and even in something like human
trafficking where we worked with the you
know LA County Sheriff's Department or
the you know the Sheriff's Department
police departments down in in Georgia
there's a very strict protocol because
after we make TV out of it those cases
have to be prosecuted right and so it's
it's it's it's a very strict protocol
and people bring it up people say I was
entrapped or you know the other common
you know
misunderstanding is that if if somebody
asks if you're the police or Chris
Hansen that you can't do anything about
it well that's not true it's just not
right and the police sort of don't want
to say that because you know it's fine
it just makes her
easier right he's yeah we're the police
okay all right are you alright are you
the police no it's they're not
committing a crime or committing and
family buddy saying no they're not the
police
yeah no it's but did you ever even on a
personal note we were there times we
were like man like because it's definite
like these got a lot of these pedophiles
and / you know and predators I mean
they're sick right there are some really
bad people in that mixture 300 so to
take cocaine around somebody that like
you know you they're addicted to cocaine
they don't have any ability to control
themselves you know doesn't it because I
struggle with wondering if it you know
like even whether it's enticement or
entrapment like what if it is sometimes
because I would feel bad sometimes
watching but if it's you I us right then
it's a real child I mean what would
happen in all these cases 300 plus cases
over gosh going on 14 years now yeah and
when you think of it I mean predators
maybe 10 15 percent of what I've done
over my career right 20 right you know
but it's just one of those franchises
yes all the attention what would happen
if the guy walks in and there is a real
1300 I'll give you an example we were
doing an investigation down in Riverside
and it was just crazy we had 51 guys in
three days and one of the guys have
walked in clearly was not a hundred
percent intellectually and he came in
the first thing I'd like mentally
challenged you mean mentally challenged
and I could see that there was a scar
like a carve out on this out of his head
where maybe he had done an injury or
something oh and in like a gang or
something no it was it was yeah an
injury okay yeah like in in he you know
was shown in the show but it wasn't a
big part of that particular show I
didn't really go hard with the interview
he left and was arrested and processed
and I thought you know there's a guy
who's got some problems and I'm not
gonna make him make him you know too
much worse he was wrong he broke the law
you'll face that with the Riverside
County Sheriff's Department the
prosecutor's office
a month later we're in Long Beach and lo
and behold the same guy services in that
investigation and in fact says I can't
make it on a Friday because I've got a
court date from the other Riverside
County case shows up on a Saturday and
in the course of him traveling to Long
Beach we find out that he did a year in
jail for a violent assault well suddenly
he's gonna make the movie you know this
is a danger yeah and while I feel sorry
for whatever injury he suffered and how
that may impact his behavior it doesn't
take anything away from the danger he
posed right and so he becomes you know
significant part of that particular
investigation and so you feel like over
time you've seen enough proof in
evidence for you where you don't feel
that you you feel your responsibility
tried-and-true if we weren't there a
real child would be you believe that I
think in many of these cases I believe
that yeah Wow is it I mean these these
profiles no yeah of course right you're
not making them make profile right
you're not yeah you guys are just
putting something into that universe
that is something they would be
intrigued by you're not making them
drive to it kids don't see the danger
I'll give another example we did some
investigating and I did this in a book
called sketcher predator some years back
and we found a case in Arkansas hmm or a
young woman of great student was in high
school the daughter of a police officer
was on a Christian Youth chatroom mm-hmm
talking to somebody who identify
themselves as a teenager in San Diego I
think named David and was harmless until
it wasn't
right when David who ends up being you
know what a lie is yeah into his 40s
there shows up in a van kidnaps her from
the home assault sir changed her to the
back of his van Wow and kills her and so
this whole panic you know starts looking
for this poor missing
missing young woman and tragically it
ended up the way it did but it was a
real wake-up call to me
and that's why I wanted to you know make
it its own chapter in the book because
it's an example of a kid who is doing
everything right and got tricked right
and that's exactly what happened he was
able to read to reverse-engineer
the information the dad was working the
night shift and there's this haunting
log of chat where she's talking to her
boyfriend and her friends were talk to
this guy - he's right it wasn't like I
want to date you what are you doing or
when are you coming to saying it a
little bit at a time
was able to get the information figure
out where she lived and he had a storage
locker all set up for the crime in a
hotel room and it was just - it was so
the risk of possibly you know of some
exploitation you feel like that no
matter what that the reward and the that
far outweighs it yeah I think so and
it's also about you know being ethical
about your storytelling right I mean
from the methodology to how you portray
someone and and you know when we do
these investigations whether it's
predator or anything else who I mean we
are absolutely transparent about the way
we do things and if you say look we do
it this way this is why we do it this is
why the police run a parallel
investigation and are there I mean you
got to remember the first three
investigations we did the first two the
police were not involved until after the
fact and it was number one socially
irresponsible to let the go another
police did make some cases after the
fact right to their credit and it was
also from a television production
standpoint it wasn't really rewarding to
the viewer and that's not what drives of
the decision why because the police was
involved because the guy walked away guy
walks away you know we have video of him
walking down the street or getting in
his pickup truck and going away yeah and
yet he's out ready to offend the next
day I mean the social responsibility is
what drove the decision to cooperate
with the police and we we you know
Duvall
protocol and so that's true it wasn't
like an element of okay we need to add
an element at the end where it's like
the guy gets NAT like it's edu actually
it actually came from a place you feel
like of social responsibility it did and
it also meant accuse you no no no I'm
just I'm just telling you how I went
down which was you know we were we had
done the two we had done the one in Long
Island New York and we had done the one
in a suburb outside of DC and we were
looking to do the next investigation and
I don't know whether they reached out to
us or we reached out to them but we got
in contact with the Riverside County
Sheriff's Department and you know a lot
of lawyer inge and a lot of you know
meetings went on and and to do this in
the appropriate fashion and I think we
we've done it all along both at NBC and
at crime watched alien in down the road
and in how we you know distribute the
next enhanced vs. predator yeah and what
does Hanson doing now against predators
like what's going on and then we're
developing you know the next the next
investigation as we speak we pretty much
know where it's gonna be the teams all
on board and we're we're really just
deciding you know where it's gonna go
and in fact some of the meetings I have
out here in LA revolve around oh great
yeah that's awesome yeah I was thinking
with the meet to movement right and a
lot of that would you ever consider
doing a like a To Catch a Predator type
of show type of show in that world not
saying that they're sexual like
pedophiles
but in the corporates war space or
anything like that it's in the works
there's a lot of that out there there's
there's a lot of talk about it yeah yeah
and and there are people who would like
to to see me do it and I've had meetings
about it and you know again it's harder
to do something like that right there's
a lot of legalities I'm sure there's a
lot of legalities a lot of gray I mean
what's wrong is wrong I mean if you're a
boss you should not be hitting on an
employee or writing some of the stuff
that those have been accused of out on
this side of the country and could you
say there would be a softer it would be
well I think you would need you would
need to have people come to you and say
this is my horrific story okay and then
you would have to go backwards and say
okay how do we capture this you know on
hidden camera how do
we prove it how do we show viewers what
happened how do we take viewers inside
the crime right and then figure out a
way to do a confrontation we just can't
go you know being outdoors and in
private offices around the country but
you know there are ways to do it and you
know if the right cases come along we're
you know we know this is what's
happening and we know it's wrong we know
it's illegal or actionable that you know
we'd take a look at doing it it's
interesting man yet cuz I grew up my
mother was a you know provided for me
and my siblings and so I remember there
were times where I know she was you know
trying to get involved with different
business her move up in her ladder and I
there were just times I even felt as a
child that whatever you know maybe mom
like she'd been taking advantage of her
like I even as a kid I remember getting
a specific feeling like like not like a
man had mistreated her and I think was
any woman of a certain age has a story
about you know looking back on a
situation saying ooh that was a little
creepy right that was inappropriate and
you know what was accepted in even
newsrooms across the country in the 70
to 60 seventies eighties is just you
know it's people look at it to the
inside long how did that even happen
yeah now you know you couldn't say like
you know get you you know get your bosom
up Ronda we got this cyber you know as a
young young reporter an anchor
having a general manager walk in and
berate my female co-anchor who also did
the weather because yeah a certain part
of our Anatomy was covering Montana yeah
and just in front of the newsroom yeah
and having her apologize yeah today
she'd get it was crueler than that all
the spare you're right the exact
language but you know I look back on
that stuff and this is like 1981-82 yeah
and you know he'd been fired for sure
and here you have this a woman who's
just trying to do her job
Roger a good reporter and and she's
apologizing because of a part of her
Anatomy was covering that you know the
lousy weather map that we had in that
market in 1982 I mean it's insane to
think that that happens yeah I mean the
whole newsroom that map might had three
indiana's on her who knows I don't know
what it was yeah it was it was pretty
cheap um no it is interesting in
but it's also we're in a time now where
we're kind of prosecuting historically
sometimes in a weird space in the world
so yeah it's interesting it's like
things that I would say even 15 years
ago or 20 years ago to someone almost
anyone man or woman some things it's
like man when I watch even old stand up
I'm like man I couldn't even say oh yeah
now yeah I it's you know it's changed
for the better you know I hope it
doesn't continue over yeah I don't write
well I don't think so either
I swing him back a little bit I'm
feeling it in the comedy world right I'm
feeling things start to like enough is
enough like I do think some things have
needed to be noticed we do need to
notice like you know what a lot of women
have been through like even as you said
like we're talking in the beginning
about like victims like women are always
kind of the victim the victim a lot of
times absolutely and especially in the
workplace I mean again whether it's your
mother
or you know your significant other your
girlfriend or I mean everybody of a
certain age has a story yeah that
looking back they might have just
laughed off or said ah ha ha you're
hysterical and you know made sure they
didn't get put one on one with that
person again right but you know it's
unfair yeah fundamentally yeah
fundamentally it's unfair and I think
we're getting that place in society now
where it's like yeah it's like we're
getting to a place where we're starting
to be able to look back at what we've
done it's almost like a comfortable
level and a comfortability we're getting
there where we can look back and like
see okay here are some ways where things
could have maybe been different do you
feel like did you have a good
relationship with Hollywood have you
always had a good relationship with
Hollywood yeah but it's you know it's
it's pretty limited you know my
relationship with Hollywood is a cameo
appearance on 30 rock or blackish right
right you know on Will Ferrell's Funny
or Die you know I enjoy that it's it's
fun stuff to do it gets you out there
but I mean even with your own show like
when you're like like when you went like
did things get weird at the end of
predator you know like was there any
like issues with Hollywood like were
they well you
show up as the impetus for a
law-and-order or CSI Miami or you know
you saw a different version of yourself
being played in an entertainment world
which is always interesting it almost
jumped the shark a little bit still
today I mean you know I remember getting
a phone call one of the guys who does my
security also did security for Saturday
Night Live mmm and Ronnie Knight is a
former NYPD and had his own security
company for years and I still bring him
out of retirement for you know that's
his predator yeah track him I just asked
me shot out Ronnie can you still shoot
straight that's all I want to know you
know so huh he calls me one day said hey
Bill hader's doing you tonight on SNL so
I got to the I got to the rehearsal and
I was watching and they did the whole
thing that Chris Hansen show where you
know they had different actors and SNL
portray you know Hollywood celebs and so
they'd walk out and in hater who was
imitating me it would pop up from behind
the desk it made a band and the whole
thing he said what are you doing here
you know and the guests would say well I
just came here to be interviewed you
invited me and you show us what's in the
bag because I don't know your producer
told me to walk out with it you know and
so they absolutely pull out the you know
that whatever is in there condoms and
whatever else and then he he said you
can go well you didn't ask you any
questions oh I'm done with you now he
goes out and he gets arrested so I'm
sitting in the audience and I they come
out of the dress rehearsal to take their
bow and I see hater and Heeter sees me
because I'm in the front row that and
he's like this I said it's fine I get it
was there like as you started to become
very famous you know because that's
happened over your career and and you
know Fame is a different thing you know
and like and in my even in this year of
my career my career is like
exponentially increased right and to me
it's like it's it's I'm grateful and at
the same time it's a little alarming
because I get it scared of my own ego
and like things that can happen if I get
a wrong idea of myself you know did any
did you start to notice some of that in
your world like yeah just the
recognition factor you know taking my
kids to a baseball game or
just you know in general being out in
public you know especially here in LA
there's a lot of that and you know New
York yeah you get stopped on the street
but it's cool but it's also for to me
it's cool and it's also scary how did
you kind of interpret some of that I
know you've had a long career like you
know my best friend I wanted to be
journalists we wanted to be broadcast
journalists we were young and and he
started in like in Mississippi and even
to a market and uh you know some small
markets and you made your way up - yeah
- anchor wwl in New Orleans oh yeah
it was just neat because he did that
process and I kind of did it broadcast
from a stage as a sign up phone exactly
but um but it once you start to get
popular and stuff people start to look
did you start to notice that and feel
that like how did that kind of
definitely it you know there was always
there was always some recognition right
you know especially the morning after a
piece would air you know people would
stop and talk to her ask about it or do
whatever and and in very much in law
enforcement circles because so much oh
that's interesting
you know Kapil stop you walking through
thank you or didn't yeah they just want
to chat or take a picture or something
like that but you know we I was with my
son's I'm from Detroit and and I'm back
there a lot we sorry about your lines
Bennett I know I was that we were at the
Thanksgiving oh really a game yeah ma
you're wonderful seeds of course you
watch the Lions you know do very well
against the Bears in the first half and
then yeah put a hell in a handbag yeah
I'm a big Barry Sanders that's a whole
IMT Anna a big Lions fan from Wichita a
lot of people notice and that didn't
know that about Barry Sanders from
Wichita you know I wouldn't been able to
answer that question that's kind of
interesting but I'm anyway yeah I'm a
Saints fan so we're doing good this year
but but I've always uh you know BJ
Armstrong I see him at the gym II used
to play for the Chicago Bulls and he's
like a big a Lions fan you know where BJ
Armstrong went to a high school mm-hmm
brother Rice high school
there were you in I'm pretty sure it was
murder right high school I shouldn't I
went to brother Rice in Birmingham
Michigan yeah but I don't like that he's
a he's a supersuit I have it in my mind
and he would her brother you have two
brother eyes yeah brother right superb
man right
yeah I thought so he was in Michigan
yeah that's where I went yeah that's
where I went to high school now he was
probably five years younger than me yeah
but he was a standout yeah he's always
been ooh he's a big Lions fan is all
gets her like why where all the Lions I
mean we're you know we're Paul and I
were sitting right there I just you know
come on let's do it yeah but I think I
think people Michigan Detroit
appreciated the appreciate you know see
me with my game cutting down a Christmas
tree right you know in the suburbs I
think they appreciate being a tiger the
game or a Lions game and you know you're
I very much have a presence there in
fact one of the shows I'm working on one
of the new shows is is a crime based
show that's gonna be a lot of Detroit
yeah and you know I still feel very
connected there I'm there that's awesome
yeah
that's really cool to hear man if
there's ever anything that I can do as a
comedian to come and do like a
fundraiser something let me know sure
yeah that's cool you know one thing I
noticed we grew up in like kind of like
an impoverished area and we would get
more we would get a lot of those sex
offender registry cards on our door a
lot because a lot of poor neighborhoods
can't keep they don't have HOAs that can
like you know even hypothetically scare
off pedophiles and predators sometimes
so I remember being you know in a lot of
environments where you would have
neighbors that you know were abused or
you know guys that were doing things
that were illegal you know and it was a
little it wasn't common but it was more
part of the world in more of like an
impoverished area because there aren't
any HOAs you know parents are working
there's only a single-parent family a
lot of latchkey kids yeah and it gets I
just remember being kind of scary so
even if there's ever anything that I can
do know I appreciate help be a part of
them and I would gladly come and uh I
try to do stuff like that for not only
groups that you know raise money for
awareness of issues with kids but also
you know the opiate addiction crisis
yeah and I try to do stuff yeah well we
had a lot of America it's it's you know
I was looking at there were 70,000
overdoses overdose deaths in America not
in 2017
and twenty-eight thousand four hundred
of them were fentanyl hmm involved and
it's a you know more than car racks more
than gunshots more than bread while the
thing isn't done think about that yeah
it has gotten so bad that for the first
time the life expectancy of an American
has dropped by 1/10 of a year do you
think it's like as humans where do you
think we're running out of like a desire
to engage in life or something do you
think there's a bigger thing going on
that we're not seeing besides the fact
that the medicine itself is addictive
well I think it's out there more I mean
you know I graduated from Michigan State
University in 1981 and when I started
there weed was decriminalized just right
in in East Lansing and Ann Ann Arbor
were University of Michigan is and so it
wasn't a big deal the drinking age was
18 if you want to have a few beers you
had a few beers and you know people had
you know pot around the dorm rooms and
nobody didn't seem like anybody was
really abusing it what is mystery and
then you know it sort of went away with
the war on drugs and obviously cocaine
and crack and I watched that as a
reporter Detroit what they'd been troit
and the drug dealers and and you know
that was front lines of that Chambers
Brothers and whiteboy trick and all that
I mean I'd lived that you know in the
eighties and nineties you know right and
think of it and and I think with the
advent of of you know the opiates I
think so many young people follow that
same road where you know somebody shows
up freshmen or sophomore year with a
bottle of this stuff yeah and you're all
good with it for a long time and you
take one once a week or on a Friday
night or Saturday night and suddenly it
snaps back and it owns you and you can't
get it you can't get the prescription
you can get it on Craigslist for $60 for
two pills but you know you're trying to
stay on the budget that your parents set
for you and what you can earn yeah and
in suddenly you can't get it in you're
desperate and so heroin is
way cheaper these kids start snorting
the heroin then they figure out if they
inject it they only do it once a day as
opposed to three times a day and then
they're into that almost a necessity at
a certain point that leads them down so
that's why they call chasing the dragon
you know you're always chasing that
first high is that synonymous a little
bit you think with the pornography and
how it can lead people down well I think
addictions addiction whether it's
alcohol or drugs or pornography or you
know any number of things but I think
that this is opiate crisis and you know
like a year ago we did this story in
outside of Dayton Ohio right around
Dayton in Montgomery County Ohio which
per capita had the highest number of
overdoses in the country and who's to
think they had Mexican cartel members
while living in Dayton Ohio because it's
way safer to be there and the Sheriff's
Department and the task force was very
aggressive
we rode with them and literally they
were doing a buy-bust
and while the confidential informant was
waiting for the dealer to buy the heroin
so they'd bust him another dealer came
by and threw her pack and said hey try
this it's got my phone over on it's
cheaper and better this way that in a
snowstorm yeah indeed no harass routes
marketing but I mean no it's yeah that's
what's happening it's happening
everywhere everywhere in the country
yeah no it's it's wild man like you know
like you know I go to like a lot of
meetings and stuff like that and in the
in that recovery universe and it's sad
man I mean it's um especially when you
see young people you know and that's the
saddest thing I think you know even here
in some of your stories is like because
you know when it's wild how sometimes
I'm still a child in some ways but in
other ways like you know at least now I
can get a perception things I can see
what's going on I have a clear view of
the world a little bit and yeah how
susceptible you realize you were when
you were a kid and almost how grateful
you were that something just didn't come
along that locked you into something
that you couldn't know what always
strikes me is you know the random nature
this stuff in crime this person made a
left-hand turn and ended up being you
know carjacked and killed this person
with the other way
is fine this person was presented with a
roommate who had interrupt drugs this
person didn't it doesn't make them that
are bad but it's just you know what if
they had not been presented with that
opportunity and never took the pill yeah
it's it's it's vexing and and you know I
what's interesting is the level of
prescriptions being written for opiates
has gone down yet the overdose is still
rising so it'll be interesting to see
with all this education awareness
treatment what happens when they
tabulate 2018 to see if it hopefully
starts to come down when you do shows
like to catch a predator are you do you
feel like you are doing that for kids do
you feel like you are doing that too is
it entertainment
do you just in your own person do you
feel like there's a obviously there's an
entertainment value right I mean you
know there's no question having said
that you know I feel that I'm doing it
for parents and kids right parents
I understand the ratings value the
popularity of it and I understand why
and there are undeniably some humor as
well as I mean you think you know some
some guy put together at the top five
most humor as well
yes went to all this week it was 10
million hits yeah 12 million hits some
bad i mean it's people just watch over
and people know the characters yeah you
know what i do i do feel like it's
deterred a lot of people probably from
going down that road of getting caught
in the internet and staying indoors and
good homes dark circles i hope so
and again it comes back to raising
awareness and creating a dialogue but it
still stuns me
I mean the last investigation we did I
identified myself I'm Chris Hansen he
said no you're not oh yes I am
oh no you're not I said well look I get
the first investigation I did was in
2004 but I don't look that much time and
I certainly sound the same you know I
mean you know I'm a bit off my diet
five or ten pounds but I mean it's Chris
Hansen trust me
I ever thought I've opened like a chair
store like have a seat I thought about
that it was interesting the second
investigation we did as I mentioned
earlier was outside of Washington DC and
it was at the home of a longtime
acquaintance who was a retired FBI agent
and that was one of the investigations
where a guy came in naked hmm and you
know imagine that scene there's a
whipped-cream guy - was it saying that
was the other naked guy that was in that
was in Florida so the Washington DC guy
comes in and he comes in naked and you
know I had the towel on top of the
refrigerators had lunch wrapped that
everybody sat on this stool hmm and so
that stool became famous name I said
yeah you may what I have that
disinfected
the fellow Greg Schwartz sent it to
another friend of ours Danny Dietz in
Detroit and said this is a piece of you
know predator remember better history
he's got it sealed in plastic huh in a
closet someplace I've got a small museum
people would go see I bet a small Fed to
catch a predator museum or the Chris
Hansen Museum I bet people would go to
see different artifacts from that type
of stuff I mean there's just such an
infatuation with it there's such a
curiosity I'm trying to think of a
couple of other like do you think that
after having seen a lot of these people
that have these diseases of being
predators or and I don't know if it's
and I might use some of the terminology
wrong right but do you think that it's a
sickness that can be repaired sometimes
I think sometimes look I think these
guys break down to three different
categories and I'm not a psychiatrist
but based upon everything I've seen and
done and and I've interviewed some of
the top people in this field
mm-hmm and in one of the problems in
society is they're not enough men and
women in this field it's not a glamorous
segment of medical practice right I mean
do you want to be the doctor who spent
how many countless years studying to be
a specialist and spend your time in in
prisons talking to child sex offender
right right people who are addicted to
child porn is that what you want to do
now there are some very dedicated people
who do some very important work and many
of them are connected
US Marshals who you know sort of on a
federal level are in charge of you know
monitoring the the sex offenders around
the country we'd love to have one of
those people and it'd be really
interesting it is it'll set us off I'll
look you up we have the O rated guy
who's based out of it the Washington DC
area cool but you know they break down
into three different categories one is
you know the heavy hitter would be doing
this with or without the internet and
can't be cured mm-hmm
the second one is you know as we
discussed earlier the guy who wouldn't
be doing this without the internet
24-hour access the addictive nature and
and the anonymity right and so these
guys you know they're do it doesn't make
it any less wrong but they get hooked
into the whole online culture and then
there's young guys as we discussed who
are you know mopey and antisocial and
there's trying to make some sort of a
connection right and if they're 19 or 20
and they're talking to a girl who's 13
or 14 well in two years theoretically it
would be legal okay
I think they think that way and those
are the guys who'd get rapped on the
knuckles and probably probably get never
do it again but you know we had a case
in the last investigation where you know
guy walked in and he was 19 but he was a
towering presence and he went in for the
hug that this girl and it was it was
disturbing now the guy ended up breaking
down in the interview and you know
saying I'm a loser and I'm overweight
and we want to be a cop but I can't do
that and I you know I can't make friends
you know it's a parent yeah how do you
feel sorry for him so that's what it
turns in to me saying look you know as
bad as this situation is you know go to
your parents get some help straighten it
around you know get it get it kid going
to the right Drive and is that genuine
from you when you say that yeah I don't
want to see this 19 year old kid yet
yeah but at the same time you know we've
got them talking to two different decoys
posing as you know 12 or 13 year old
girl right and if they were real it's
gonna happen right right yeah no it look
man I love it I love it cuz this is you
know that's a question I've always had
from watching to catch the predator and
some of those types of things so it's
good to hear like it's good to think of
putting those things on the scale and
think
about what the that which one really you
know Kim way heavier if it gets out of
hand you know so to the young guys who
were struggling to a young guy who maybe
you know spends a lot of time by himself
online and he's looked at too much
pornography and maybe he's got into some
strange spaces what what kind of
suggestions do you do you tell those the
guys like that if there are any
listening you know cuz I mean it's a I
think that the the pornography and that
kind of stuff is really it can be an
opiate you know and I think there are
therapists who specialize in this yeah
and I think there are programs just for
alcohol and drugs yeah for you know yeah
their sex addiction love addiction and
you know you see this all the time with
these poor women you talk about being
victimized you know on these sweetheart
swindles and this is a story that I've
been wanting to do for a long time it is
you know I'm not talking about a guy who
is trying to meet women online who is
you know saying he's got a PhD when he
only has you know masters know what
somebody who says they're an astronaut
when they've got a criminal history
right you know I mean it's a big
difference here but you see that all the
time even we've done the you know the
stories where the these women are
vulnerable they're working two jobs to
support their kids and they're only
social outlet is online is online and
these guys know that and whether it's a
you know Nigerian style scam where
they're looking for money or they're
having a buy electronics and they're
selling them and you know we've seen it
all mm-hmm you know we had a case one
time we were doing the Nigerian scams
and we we set up a drop site or we're
looking for a drop site and we found one
that was in outside of Rochester New
York and we knocked on the door we posed
his delivery guys was CH delivery and
the slogan was we absolutely positively
guarantee you're gonna get it so we
deliver a bunch of calls there okay yeah
it not looking yet so we we finally get
the guy who's getting all the packages
and we want to get him into a controlled
environment where we could do a
hidden-camera interviewing so I'm in a
warehouse office and all these boxes and
I'm hoping he doesn't touch the boxes
because they're all empty
mm-hmm and I'm not really undercover I
mean I've got a switcher two tigers ball
cap on and
sitting there I said well you know how
did you meet this woman for whom you are
you know taking delivery of all this
stuff and he said well I met her online
but he said you got to be really careful
on those chat
besides I said why is that he goes well
that Chris Hanson you know he's out
there he's gonna catch you and I'm
sitting I said I said yeah he's pretty
sharp guy and I want to say he's
handsome too but I thought this is on
camera you know good posture
well actually the guy and so we have
back is not playing this is just so this
is a place out dose you know that and
again I'm not I didn't you know I've
done stuff undercover where the makeup
here I figured on and they'll make me
dirty and messy and they're all that but
this is you know basically with the
fleece and a ball cap yeah and he just
laid it all out there and so we had him
back again I said look you know I got to
tell you you know I am you know and jaw
dropped in and I said we're we're gonna
try me he was an innocent victim yeah
and he was getting played right you know
and he had this you know this woman was
you know said pictures and real you know
look her and of course it wasn't yeah
reality is fake the scammers had gotten
the picture from some place you know we
traced it back to a Danish soft porn
ya know swimsuit site or something that
they just clipped it yeah when I used to
sometimes I used to do drugs and I would
be at night and I would look at like
pornography and stuff on the internet
you know I did it like I would be by
myself and that was my kind of thing
like I wasn't out party and I would you
know do some cocaine and stuff by myself
at home right em audience knows about
this and so and I would find myself I
would you know you start looking at
escort sites and stuff like that and
then a lot of those pictures they're not
even real like it's all if there's just
such a scam
there's so much of a of a scam online
it's such a fake world just go to
Craigslist sometimes yeah you know and
they got rid of the site that advertised
yeah the casual encounters yeah but but
it exists in other places within
Craigslist and you know I'm not casting
aspersions on Craigslist but the reality
is that you know there are millions and
millions and millions of people buying
and selling things across the world at
any given moment and Craigslist has you
know 40 or 50 people monitoring now they
cooperate with law enforcement they they
do their due diligence but
it's almost uncover noble right and so
when we do a human trafficking
investigation oftentimes it is you know
on a site like like that and it's it's
it can be premix list is is is you know
we purchase drugs we found alleged
hitman we've seen all kinds of stuff
a hitman things interesting yeah yeah I
might save me a cross from them and
Brian Park one afternoon really I can
give you the price list it Kurt or make
somebody disappeared really oh yeah
it's a mafia Napoleonic Code I'm from
Louisiana and so there they have like if
you lose an arm you get there's no
lawsuit like you got 40 grand
yeah I'm saying this know it's like
pirate law yeah you know like you lose a
thumb that's eleven thousand when I go
on a court right come pick up your check
I'm trying to think of one uh question
that I've had it was specifically Nick
is there anything else that you think of
I was just wondering if there's any
people that you're fans of that you
found out we're big fans of you in the
show and like or like massive fans yeah
if you ended up in any wildly cuz
somebody said you know Chris Hanson I
want you to be at this event and then
you're like next thing you know you and
Mike Tyson her plan you know squash
together uh you know I'd met some people
over the years you know celebrities
inside shoot one who I won't embarrass
but I was at the US Open once and
sitting in a nice you know box some
sweet typesetting and a big tennis fan
and and try to play as much as possible
and an actor came up to me and he had
just gotten engaged as a fiance was
there he pulls me aside he said hey I
got a thank you sir my well you know the
girl I did it before her she just gets
so turned on when we watch her show
gotta help a brother out
oh nice man yeah it's uh was there um
did you seeing the shows and being a
part of to catch a predator and and did
it adjust the way that you raised your
own children you know or did it maybe
Keisel for the way you'd raised your own
G yeah I you know it
you know they watched it with me on the
couch mm-hmm you know and they grew up
in an environment where you know FBI
agents were over socially Wow judges
other reporters you know the you know I
joke my oldest son his first assignment
was he was 18 months old and I had him
in a backpack and I was at a gun and
knife show in Detroit on 8 mile at the
Armory and you know I had a hidden
camera hidden in the baby that guy it's
gonna work for you're gonna work even
more interest what'd you guys do today
oh nothing you know and they're all look
kind of cute baby and I've got that you
know they've got the tribe last illegal
you know
trigger additions to make a
semi-automatic automatic and then you
know so he went along in that and got
the video and got back the car and we're
driving back home and this is in Detroit
as I said in and almost home and the
pager and cell phone goes off and and
dr. Kevorkian had you know performed a
medicide you know on those so we pull in
there and you know the producers you
know got him and then I'm doing a live
shot for the suicide Wow Saturday on
another Kevorkian incident but yeah so
they they've always been around it you
know and and so they I never you know
said you should go into it right but I
was gonna prevent them from doing it
yeah and it's interesting as one is so
behind the scenes you know he said one
just got his first news or job someone
he's a reporter who's been a reporter
for last two years up in Traverse City
Michigan L&I station and he just got a
job in Oklahoma City which is a nice
jump and I think oh yeah it's a bigger
market yeah and so I'm gonna drive out
with him I think get him settled and get
back to work myself is it on do you
enjoy being a dad is it fun yeah I mean
it's it's it mean I have a very cool
situation because you know I've got you
know the two oldest her 27 24 and then
you know my significant others kids who
I'm very close with are gonna be 19 and
and our 17 so you know I learned a lot
right and it's sometimes easy to I never
had someone who was the daughter before
so it's you know the that's a little
different thing but it's it's the the
they're both great everybody gets along
it's a nice blended situation yeah and
you know it's really pretty cool but but
you do learn some stuff so when you get
a shot at being helpful or as I say I'm
just an unpaid advisors oh yeah I'm
gonna be fertilized at the end of the
day talk to your
she who's in charge yeah do you um do
when you look forward to like the future
of like I guess almost a lot of the the
guys you caught on to gets predator
we're men yeah
all through a reason well if you ask the
people who really know the psychology of
it they'll tell you that when it comes
to female predators you're more likely
to see the teacher in the students right
because the female predator doesn't get
off on the anonymity where the male
predator is someone who likes the
anonymity and it gives them a sense of
it's like a hunting thing or something
young maybe or just I don't know what's
gonna happen right mm-hmm
yeah man it's fascinating after meeting
a lot of these people face-to-face do
you feel like there's just did it make
you feel worse about humanity or better
about humanity or it haven't even effect
on you like that well it's you know I
was on Jon Stewart Show on Tommy said
you know what do these guys have in
common I said with have in common as
they typically don't stand out in a
crowd they don't have you know the word
predator emblazoned on their forehead
and in scarlet letters it could be the
guy you know standing next to you at the
grocery store or the dry cleaner and to
which Stewart said I didn't find another
dry cleaner they don't stand out in the
crowd yeah you know it's it's it's guys
who you know have darkness within them
who are committing this crime after
doing stand-up for about 14 years or
whatever I've been doing it you know I
start to get a sense of the crowd when
I'm there but I can tell in the first
couple of like moments like where the
laughter is coming from everybody's
having a good time if people aren't I
can get a vibe if somebody in the
distance is like um starting to pay
their check or if they're them and their
wife even aren't getting along at a
certain point you really get some kind
of keen senses do you start to have
those senses when you're just out in the
regular world absolutely sexual
predators and pet like people that might
be deviant well that's tough to do I
mean right it is you have to do but do
you feel like it at moments that there's
any because I do it only building you
yes you've had that much experience but
honestly I can't decide whether it's
just me being right you know overly
suspicious as somebody who may look
overly suspicious or you know whether
I'm just you know reading it into
something you know but but I do know
what you're talking about in terms of
the vibe because you know I give a lot
of speeches and and and do a lot of
fundraisers and you know when you're
engaged yeah you know when you're on a
roll you know when you own them you know
when you you know you lean into the bike
and people are listening ya know and
it's you know you have to remember that
when you're doing the broadcast when
you're doing an interview with somebody
and you know take them on that journey
of discovery and kind of just get in
their heads and you know peel it away
like an onion yeah yeah man it's just uh
have you ever been like at a dinner
party and a man's come over you and said
hey Chris I'm having a problem like on
the side or something like that you know
frequently all good people approach me
and you know public setting is insane or
even you know on the internet on social
platforms to say I was victimized oh wow
and thank you for the show and and and
probably makes me feel comfort in some
way well it does and you end up be
hearing all about it whether it was a
you know a priest thing or you know
teacher thing or you know stepfather
thing and you know it's it's you know on
one hand it's like okay you know I'm
glad we're able to be helpful and and
you know they're just really reaching
out to say you know it's ooh the pain a
little bit yeah and I just can't imagine
yeah you know being victimized that way
yeah we're having a child who is
victimized
I mean that's the dark arts I'd come
unglued if it happened to a lot loved
one I mean honestly I just I don't know
that I could be the guy who just stood
back and I mean it were just yeah I mean
it's wrong that it happens any whatever
cool I'm saying you sure you know yeah
you're trying to you know how you would
feel if that was in your world yeah yeah
no it's striking I mean it's a huge
thing I think it's what you know it's a
dar it's such a darkness I think that's
why you know like you're saying it's so
fascinating people you know it's just
such a it's such a taboo kind of well
and you know most people thankfully go
through life without being the victim of
a crime yeah you know and again I and
get a cue sometimes of creating fear
amongst my loved ones about
you know coming and going and parking
lots and lots and doors and you know the
usual stuff but you know I've seen some
random stuff where people in safe areas
get victimized just by being at the
wrong place at the wrong time yeah and
it's not always you know a diabolical
serial killer like in the movies I mean
it's it's just advanced kids who are
take advantage and make a wrong decision
and suddenly they're they're criminals
um do you uh do people I'm sure you've
had an instance where you just like went
to sit in an area at an airport or
something and some dudes saw you come
and sit near him and lost freak just got
super scared oh yeah you know like
people must think anywhere you go I mean
I
you were standing in the lobby at at
discovery you know on Third Avenue in
New York City you know with my roller
bag that's sitting right over there yeah
and feel like wait what one time I was
looking at was years ago and it might
even have been before predator but we
had just done some hidden camera stuff
and I was looking at an item in the guy
show it to me and sweat starts pouring
out of his forehead
oh I said hey man you all right you know
it was just last minute Christmas
shopping yeah and he says do you have a
hidden camera on me right now I said no
no no I man just you know you know on
47th kind of figure something out at the
latitude a light saber brother you know
yeah to come chill I've seen a massage
chair god I went I went to the pharmacy
in the office building and and my doctor
had prescribed a bunch of different
antibiotics so travel overseas hmm so
there's you know there's five different
antibiotics and if you were to take them
all together you could get sick or die
but that's not the point of it the point
of it was to have it and if I got sick I
could call the doctor and say what
should I do and you could say okay take
this one for that and so the pharmacist
looked at me he said I'm gonna fill this
but are you trying to trick me into
giving you know too many of the wrong
things with counter engine no no I just
I carry this with me it's it's you know
it's it's approved by my doctor yeah
this is just what I do when I travel
overseas you know have you ever gotten
to meet John wall's
yeah I know John Wall do you really go
yeah
he and I I did some work for the
National Center for Missing and
Exploited Children and was honored to
receive a award from them a few years
back and and got to know John through
that and John does some stuff with
LexisNexis and luckiest Nexis was very
helpful to us you know we had sort of a
cooperative effort on some investigative
stories so yeah John's great guy is he a
really neat man he's a good I was
actually down in Florida just after that
case occurred and I just could not
imagine you know having gone through
that and you know the strain on a
relationship the loss of a you know
young child and I you know there's a lot
of things I could survive but I I give
him and his wife as well just such great
credit for the way they've channelled
this into yeah something positive yeah
it's right you know when you say that
yeah there was something about them that
made it so like you can see the like
what's going on on his face so well like
it made it so human like it made it yeah
so and here's a young couple who you
know had it all starting their life life
down in Florida and suddenly the Adams
gone yeah and you know I started in
Tampa I went from Lansing to Tampa after
that occurred but it wasn't too long
after and one of my cameramen was
actually working in on the east coast of
Florida when they found is the Adams
head floating in a canal and just God
who just in act he would tell the story
and you could see just being the
cameraman out there it just affected him
at such a level and he just never you
know it was seared into his into his
mind yeah yeah man I think yeah I think
it just made that kind of stuff just so
human to everyone you know and
especially watching he and his wife he's
how he saw the relationship part but
then still have the foundation they they
held it together and you know I you know
there as far as I know I mean I don't
pretend to be you know right in contact
with him regularly but oh I thought
there was appointment and I could be
wrong I thought there was a point during
I remember seeing the movie or reading
something where I thought that they they
took out like they had to separate from
each other at a point because they were
just losing their mind I think they all
pulled it back
yeah both um today what a fascinating I
mean what a sad sir but what a
fascinating story Nick anything else we
have this is Nick from Maryland Chris
Hansen huge fan to questions or two-part
question whatever these guys always seem
to come up with crazy excuses as to why
they're there I guess not knowing that
you already know so what's the funniest
or craziest wildest one that you've ever
heard and then the second part would be
what's the craziest thing that's
happened that's never been on you know
aired on TV well I'll take the second
one first
everything has aired right that was
appropriate but there's no one scene
that was crazy and wild that we didn't
put on okay I mean we might have had to
edit around rough language or rough
video or pictures that the predator may
have sent but everything that happened
the viewer saw yeah in terms of the the
excuses I mean I've heard them all I was
just coming over to take care of the
young woman to make sure she didn't do
anything wrong until her mother got home
yeah they had one eye I thought the
house was for sale is it who told it the
house is for sale well my friend I said
what's your friend's name
Oh Roger I said what's Rogers phone
number I pulled my cell phone is it
let's call Roger right now and see how
he found out this house is wrong and and
we had one down in Florida where the guy
shows up and he's a real estate because
I could even he just pulled it again he
said well I thought the house is for
sale
hmm I said so you didn't just write down
the number on the sign and where's the
sign well there's no sign yeah he said
well you know then I saw the young woman
and she was waving at me and I wanted to
make sure she was okay um you know
they're talking on the phone they're
texting back and forth so he walks you
in and I'm reading him the transcripts I
said you said this to someone who
identified themselves is it 13 14 who
said no I would never say that my
computer's in my office which is
upstairs my home and my wife and
daughter were downstairs I said well let
me read further wow I have to be very
careful talk to you like this because my
wife and daughter are downstairs I'm up
in my office since it was there um and
what was it was that both
the question yeah yep okay was there um
was there an is there an is there an
arch-nemesis out there that you've
always wanted to catch that you haven't
been able to like that big like a big
fish you know not really you know a lot
of these things develop as as you know
crime has become not more popular but
but you know more active hmm and you
know you sort of see a trend coming
whether it's the opiates or whether it's
human trafficking and you you know you
pursue that if you find along the way
that there is a person who is the
kingpin of this particularly chronic
yeah of course you want to pursue that
but do you have one that swims around on
the back of your head where you're like
oh you know if some of there's a dark
artist out there that I need to catch
you know know there was a story a case a
series of killings in suburban Detroit
when I was in high school called the
Oakland County child killer and the
victims were both male and female and
this one hits home because a family that
I became friendly with later in life as
a reporter had lost a child in this
string of killings and it was just
bizarre and random and and good kids
from good homes you know nobody was at
risk and and and there are theories as
to who the killer was or perhaps there
were two killers because they were male
and female victims but they never have
charged the case and it has always
haunted me you know I'd love to be able
to solve that I'd like to get be able to
give the family closure on that yeah and
and again there there have been some
people identified over the years and
I've reported on it and but nothing ever
definitive no charges were ever brought
hmm but say it huh yeah I mean this goes
back to the late 70s
do you feel a little bit like you have a
responsibility to bust people or not I
mean I and I used term bus like I don't
even know but do you feel like you have
a responsibility to catch these
predators because you have such a
profile in that space now like you feel
like like there's this ticking time
clock like you know even just with your
own life and livelihood I mean I know
you're still pretty young but even but
but it's like you know I have this
platform you know and we in and in
because that's a rare platform it's like
you know you're right and whether it's
you know the actual you know child
predators right you know predators
targeting children is a better way to
put it or something else I mean yeah I I
feel like I have this currency that I
can use yeah and a brand that I can can
use to go route these things out and and
I have you know a great team of folks
around me who you know want to work and
and and do these things and do important
work and it's you know we this is a
funny business as you know yeah I'll go
there are periods of the year where I'm
seven days a week and then that you know
you have two months off and services are
waiting for the next thing and so it's
you know it can be a little herky-jerky
but it it does weigh heavily on me that
you know on that god yeah and and while
I love my summer time in Michigan yeah
yeah I got stuff to do yeah and I got
stuff to do I like that yeah so and
we're teeing it all up right now good a
lot of exciting stuff coming up
including more predator yeah well yeah
well we'd love to you know be able to
support in any way and I genuinely meant
that like you know I'm never offered to
go and do a show if there's some you
guys are doing for fundraising to help
with that with that was something like
that years from now yeah it's it's
either I never know it's you know I've
been fortunate you know throughout my
career to meet people in entertainment
and to you know meet people in the music
world who you know have big cars yeah
kid rocks that way yeah I've heard yeah
I know he'll pick up the newspaper in
Detroit and see somebody in distress and
tall wanted his you know read a check
and I don't want any attention just send
it over there yeah I mean he does his
stuff all the time yeah nobody you know
he doesn't seek attention for it yeah
yeah I don't know man it just I mean it
really hurts my heart when I think about
you know just kids something happening
to kids in them not being able to you
know just even realize that life can
have joy in it because something like
stunts them at such a point you know
yeah being a victim of a crime yeah or
you know there was a story in the papers
this morning about a kid in Britain of
Middle Eastern descent who was you know
harassed at school and bullied at school
and they sort of according to the story
you know
simulated waterboarding hit in the
playground and said god I mean yeah what
what makes kids were being sometimes you
know the whole bullying culture is
something that needs to be dealt with -
yeah out of that there's a lot of space
out there for you too so there's a lot
you know you're kind of a shark and
there's a lot of space for you to swim
in you know do you have to be cognizant
to your own behaviors - sometimes cuz
you worry like that you're gonna be
under such a microscope though like I
think about that sometimes like you know
like [ __ ] if I start talking about
something or being in a world am I gonna
somehow in a way that I don't even know
bring that into my own life well I you
know the truth is I'd lead it pretty you
know sedate live today it's not the
right word but but you know centered at
least in him but it's true I mean you
know you if you are the guy who's using
hidden cameras to catch people you know
you should be aware that when you're out
in public
yeah and governed yourself appropriately
yeah it's no longer an issue and when I
was young enough to be running around it
was you know mostly before the internet
and cell phones much less cell phone
videos so I yeah you know it doesn't
take much to get dusted up if you're not
paying attention all the time yeah I
watch the show you know I've seen I've
seen the show I've been in the show you
know anything else net oh yeah here's
another one would do one more year Chris
and then we'll uh we'll wrap it up
you know see oh it's Jake from
Charleston South Carolina weird hearing
your voice on the phone
I love the podcast keep pumping him out
my question for Chris Hanson is which
guy that they caught was he most freaked
out by was it the Indian guy who walked
in naked or was it the guy that they
caught twice anyway a gang gang man get
that hitter gaming bro thank you
well I think both I mean those two are
right on the topic list I remember over
the the fellow who came in naked the
second the first guy you you referred to
literally I was in like a back den of
this house and here comes this guy
nikka mm-hmm and he's moving fast faster
than I was able to get around these go
fast and naked sounds scary to me right
and this guy was talking about whipped
cream and a cat and incorporating all
this stuff with the young girl and and
so literally I go to open the door
to confront him yeah and he's got his
hand on the opposite doorknob hmm open
up and he sees Miro you know and so yeah
this whole crazy QA develops after that
and you know again with the towel and he
walks out the door with the towel and
yeah sighs to find his clothes at the
back door and and then you know the
other guy in Washington who came in
naked the next day there's all this
commotion upstairs with the online
decoys I said what's going on he said
remember the guy walked in naked last
night I said hard to forget yeah you
know he said well he's online again
trying to talk to another kid and I said
set up a meeting at the you know find a
McDonalds set of meeting so we show up
you know we leave the house which is a
little again because what if you miss
something that road yeah yeah so we go
and we watch some of the guys get video
and walking into the McDonald's and we
you know move in and not I'm trying to
think of what I'm gonna say yeah you
know cuz I got one shot and he runs it's
the you know it's over I didn't want
chase minted trafficking and you could
just seen this guy the day before the
day before make it in the kitchen of the
Taj Johnson is a bad second image on
Canal it was his name it a special guy
29 he wasn't 29 nor is he that special
yeah so he's coming out of McDonald's
and I'm there with two camera crews and
two soundmen with the booms I said John
startle I said you know I've been in
this business at the time 20-some years
and I very seldom Dannette a loss for
words
yeah but I don't know what to ask you
first I just said it because it was the
only thing that came to my mind I you
know and he looked at me says well I'm
getting help I'm getting treatment I
said John I Got News for you it's not
working yeah remember yesterday right
yeah last night and now you're out here
again and you know you hug often his red
pickup truck and and I don't know if
they ever prosecuted to him in that case
or not
I know that they found him trying to do
something with some other little kids in
a park something I don't know what
happened after that but yeah those those
were two very bizarre what are the cases
overall what do you think these
predators like to eat like they always
seem to bring a snack well they bring
snacks and obviously we have sometimes
snacks there oh yeah I seen you got the
little cupcake sometimes and that
what is they bring if they're bringing
her to their but food actually usually
fast food you know we actually got a
letter from the lawyer at one time from
Mike's Hard Lemonade
yes whatever period of time
during two or three of the
investigations that was the pit drink oh
oh rich people's Zima that was rich
people Zima exactly
so I he had this letter saying please do
not use our product so but no specific
fast food company really kind of read
was it overall that you saw like it was
just a little bit of this a little bit
of that you know and basically it's
whatever the decoy asked for Ryan many
cases there was one guy who showed up he
was a plumber in here he brought food
for himself but not for the
thirteen-year-old girl he was going to
molest that it's like really hard yeah
how you gonna molest somebody that
doesn't have any energy in the ground
it's just I mean that's not a way to
think about it right it's also like yeah
what about chick-fil-a did anybody ever
bring that not that I can recall yeah
that's awesome I like that and I don't
want to think about that way either
are there any things that you uh what
are their other stuff that you like to
do like outside like you have any games
on your phone or anything what else does
Chris Hanson like to do you know I don't
really have any games in the phone or do
the video game thing I mean I did a you
know when the kids were young obviously
and they would routinely whether it was
Guitar Hero or whatever beat me
senseless at whatever game you know I
think the last one I played was pong you
know that cry as a kid but I like tennis
and skiing and yeah you don't being out
on the water and reading you know it's
it's a I've really gotten into this
peloton bike though have you really yeah
it's really and I'm not I promise that
I'm not no it's money talk about it one
of our friends rods won one of the
biggest podcasts also is right through
this wall they're not taping today but
fighter in the kid and one of their guys
he's peloton every day yeah yeah I do it
pretty much every day because I you know
we have an apartment in New York and
then you know home in Michigan so you
know in Michigan it just lends itself
it's near Park and you know you go for
Ron and you do the hills yes up and in
New York while I enjoy running in New
York and I'm close to you know being our
walkway near the remember it just if I
can get 45 minutes right off the bat and
it's right in the bedroom and I have to
trip over it you know going to make the
coffee in the
I do it right you know and it's it's
it's a great piece of equipment it's
interactive you can take the live
classes or the classes that are taping
and for me it's just it's a great way to
ensure you know can you work out it ya
know I love hearing that man it's funny
I was just thinking about it the other
day when I see my friends on him it's up
it's like oh that's interesting who
inspired you haven't you have like
inspiration at this point you found like
inspiration has changed in your life as
you've gotten you know furthering your
career you know you know one of the
greatest compliments I've ever gotten
was I ran into Mike Wallace one time
years ago and he was still working for
60 minutes of the time and and he's so
good with people you know then I said
dad hey Mike Chris Hanson knows it with
daylight at the time he looked at me and
said Oh Kris and I was on like goofing
off that day right in Miami and he was
working he was doing the interview with
Lawrence Taylor I think he'd just
written Wow he's at a wildlife yeah I
think that's him and so yeah and yeah
Chad Wallace looks at me and says Chris
what was it that I just saw that you did
not having seen it but we knew how to
compliment a young younger version of
him and I saw was the story and the
Stinger missiles the terrorists were
trying to buy you know you know before
9/11 use oh it was so good and I felt so
you know later I sort of figured out a
system of being able to say something
nice even though he didn't have it at
the top of his head but it meant so much
to me that he would even hmm think to do
that ya know and and he you know I had
so many great classic stories over the
years you know do you feel like when you
look back just on like the work in
sexual predator do you feel person do
you feel like a hero or no no I you know
look I I think it's important I think
we've made a difference mm-hmm
you know it it built a platform for me
to do some of the stories that weren't
automatic fits in the format of a
syndicated show it's given me some
leverage to do things that I think are
important you know that you know are
highly rated but they're expensive right
you know if you're gonna go hang out and
do stuff undercover you know it's it's
it's not the murder story where you
interview the six characters and you put
it together dramatic
video I mean you got to go get it yeah
there's no guarantee I'm as much as you
try to get it set up and you weren't you
know side by side with law enforcement
so you know something could happen
that'll that'll constitute interesting
television there's no guarantee I mean
there's nothing worse than going out
talking your executive producers into
doing something spending the money yeah
and then missing the guy at the last
minute I mean we were going after a guy
it's a horrible case where this guy was
raping his 11-year old stepdaughter and
did it for like four years and we did
this story and and they had let him out
on parole yeah how they got these
nonviolent drug offenders who have been
in for 29 years they want to get this
guy out after you know Farr list right
and so we're gonna go chase him down
he's working at this plant you know was
gonna I was ball said to confront him
I'd driven around it we'd checked it out
and we're there and I just you know I
jumped the gun too early you saw and his
buddies smuggle him out a back gate
across you know and I got a call Los
Angeles and say hey Oh how'd it go was
it really good was a dramatic well it
was 20,000 down the drain today yeah
yeah there's something you know yeah
yeah it's not a good conversation right
do you feel yeah at a certain point does
it get tricky though and like you know
there's an executive there's a there's a
financial push to like get it right and
it's like you have to like did you ever
feel like at that point you're but
you're you're sacrificing integrity no
nobody's ever asked me to sacrifice
integrity oh wow and again that you know
I started television 1981 Wow when I was
still in college and making $4 in 80
cents an hour 39 hours a week and then
what full-time when I when I graduated
but honestly and I know these questions
come up with different syndicates that
own different groups of television
stations and you know how do you prove
this or Pro that or your right-wing left
way but I've never felt it ever yeah and
you know in a lot of years and yeah I
mean are there realistic constraints in
terms of budget absolutely you know do
we necessarily go around the world that
we once did you got to justify it right
and you got to make sure the audience is
there yeah
different shows used to go around the
world a lot more and now everything it's
I mean budgets are smaller and bigger
pieces production companies take bigger
pio you know overall there's back people
behind the scene who's your audience
right and do you spend a year going
undercover and going to India to expose
human drug trials of something that you
know is dangerous
but you caught them doing I mean it's
good TV it's a variety V you win and
over seas Press Club award maybe an Emmy
but you know where do you put your
resources right and that's the you know
depending on the show you know look
crime is big
look alive crime is big I've literally
got four shows in the works mile all
crime and I love crime it's it's it's
it's it's in its importance what I've
always done I mean I just didn't start
doing this you know four years ago
because it was popular you know do you
think it would be more exciting to die
of natural causes or to honestly to get
murdered be honest I just want a long
life I really but at the end though I
took everyone a long life okay but when
you get to the end of that long life I
think about this yeah I want to die of
natural causes or is there something
exciting about getting murdered I don't
want to get murdered I can accept a
horrible ski accident I can accept a
heart attack doing something that I
truly was passionate about right but I
don't need to you know have a cleanup
crew I just think it would be that lever
I just watched the equalizer - on the
plane that does seem more blood and guts
today than normal may have our flight we
talked you mentioned sex trafficking we
had a sex worker in right and she was
upset and a lot of sex workers were
upset when they shut down some of the
sites where they were able to sell their
services because you know there's such a
big sex trafficking let's stop sex
trafficking but then at the same time I
was preventing you know women who were
have been sustaining their livelihood
and supporting you know families or
whatever for a while do you think that
one just outweighs the other and it
doesn't matter
I still think women are being exploited
right you know that's got to be a tough
life you know I'm not one to say look
you know lawsuits or society should you
know arbitrate what a woman does with
their own body that's not up to me but
in my experience seeing this in doing
stories and talking to recovered section
industry workers that's not a pretty
life right I mean you sit there and you
talk to a 17 or 18 year old who was
coached into this life at 14 years old
because she was having a bad day and
somebody appealed to her yeah her
weaknesses have exploited that and a
pimp made her feel loved and put her to
work and took all the money you know oh
yeah that's right degrading showing up
in a hotel room in Cincinnati or yeah
wherever and you know being forced into
you know doing things Lou - yeah yeah
this woman was she was in her 30s I
think and it so I guess her perception
was different but I guess how these
people get into that situation and how
that all starts it's probably I'd be
willing to say and go out on a limb here
that that the vast majority of women who
find themselves in that situation are
desperate threatened or victimized in
some way that makes them vulnerable yeah
- going into it I mean you know this is
it's like you know the notion of you
know somebody working their way through
law school you know that's that's a
rarity right right right - yeah using
that gia people get jammed up in bad
situations on whatever level and resort
to this sort of thing is sex trafficking
as big of a problem or like like you
know every now and then like the live
like far liberal go you know it's like
they'll just make a post card says
700,000 women were abused yesterday yeah
there is I was caution I sit on boards
and am an adviser to you know a number
of groups airline ambassadors being one
of them which is made up of airline
employees who it started out donating
their airline parks miles to bring kids
in from third world countries you need
it extraordinary medical care and they'd
fly them into the United States for that
that medical care and then sort of
branched off into educating airline
employees to recognize
as human half again when it goes on so I
speak to because of the lot of the
stories I've done over the years I speak
to these groups and I'm on a panel that
helps educate it you know flooded heads
but you know flight attentive you know
you see a guy with with you know young
girl and for some reason it's not
doesn't fit they don't look yeah yeah
yeah I mean you get a sense about that
stuff you look at it again I caution
these groups about coming up with
numbers and extrapolating things people
say we don't how many predators online
at any given time and we one time in one
of the stories use the number 50,000 and
it could be 10 times that but the
problem is you don't know because of the
ubiquitous nature and we you know we got
rapped by some fact checkers and how do
you know and well it came out of a
speech by a State Attorney General and
then it was picked up and you know
confirmed by a FBI agent who work that
kind of crime and so it it the the
somebody traced it back but it was NPR
and to say where did this number
actually come from and I did interviews
I was very honest about I said look this
is the estimate that you know has been
commonly used and I used it to I'm
guessing that worldwide it's much higher
than right yes especially World War III
you know I always caution troops don't
put a number on it because we really
don't know what I can tell you is that
when it comes to human trafficking you
can take any big event whether it's a
Super Bowl World Series a Republican
convention a Democratic convention and I
guarantee you a fight in Las Vegas a dog
show to probably even thousands of women
will be flown into that area in traffic
right right I can guarantee yeah yeah
and you know I think I even see that I
mean I don't know any of those people
but I definitely see things where it's
like oh that makes me it sets off a bell
like I'll see things on Instagram or
social media it's like oh that's that
seems very odd that suddenly you know
these people are there for some we did a
sting with the LA County Sheriff's
Department a year or so ago and you know
within 30 minutes Drive of where we're
sitting right now in one afternoon
literally had six or eight cases yeah
you know where and who are these
predators most of that are doing that
sort of thing is that more of an
international type of thing
well it's it's both I mean you have
people who are you know importing you
know vulnerable women from you know
Eastern European bloc yeah at raised
Asia you see it within Asia and then you
see you know Tim's who are just running
local just small-game the local mall
yeah you know you recruit people and
suddenly there's money where there was
no money I remember we did story in Las
Vegas once we were doing a lot of
undercover stuff down there a few years
back and there was a young woman she had
been accepted into Air Force
intelligence she was good to go all she
had to do was show up she had passed all
the tests and she was dating a guy who
is you know kind of living on the
fringes gangster wise and he pulls up in
this BMW system on let's go for
righteous where'd you get this cuz
that's you know it's a friend's hmm what
kind of been stolen they put them both
in her in the women's lock up and him in
the men's lockup and while she's in the
lockup there's a woman there who works
for a pimp in Las Vegas who recruits her
and suddenly she goes from being an Air
Force intelligence officer yeah to being
sold on the streets of Las Vegas by a
notorious pimp right Wow to think that
they would have somebody in a prison
that that's where they would be revealed
was the lock-up was the county lockup
Brian what are unique I'm just saying
but think about if she didn't take the
ride yeah be in the Air Force yeah as
opposed to being a recovered recovering
a saturated worker yeah so there's small
things that yeah it's just like you say
sometimes it's just so moment-to-moment
how one thing could happen to somebody
in one turn or one car ride or one this
or one that so it really at that point
then you have to just be aware you have
to be cognizant on what's going on no
matter what situations you're getting
into well again it goes back to you know
why we do all these stories if you can
get into the mind of a criminal and hear
the voice of a victim you can prevent
other people from becoming victims yeah
it's really the credo of the thing and I
feel it true from this conversation that
the risk of of exploitation the risk it
I I kind of feel like it does it
outweighs you know it just weighs
heavier you know it weighs like
it's a worthwhile risk to take when you
look at the other side of the scale and
see the possibilities of things that can
be going on you know it's interesting
man do you try to stay off a certain
places on the Internet to try and keep
your own head straight yeah I mean I
don't go big on it you know I use it for
research for stories I I do you know
engage in you know promotion of projects
and stories and you know I'll wish
everybody Happy Thanksgiving all right
but you're not tablet important you
don't you have you ever had any issues
with that kind of stuff yeah this
powerful mean it's a lot of young men
you know all guys especially in it it's
it's I think your age group was more
exposed to it than my age group again
you know the only thing we ever saw ways
you know Playboy magazine 73 our game
compared to you know dude sometimes
somebody that would get a perfume thing
would get stuck in a Playboy magazine
right a woman's perfume thing so you had
like that was another universe because
then you had the you know the bosoms and
you had the scent you know you were just
like living oh man it was like having a
stepmother you know like a hot
stepmother yeah but I I don't even know
how those magazines stay in business
except except for the editorial part of
it because any young man who wants to
see anything it's until I remember years
and years ago a friend of mine was
helping his daughter with a you know
school project and it went to the I
forget was it he was on The Wizard of Oz
and he put into a search website Dorothy
and the stuff that came up Wow and this
is 10 12 15 years ago and he was like
you know cover the kids eyes yeah just
you know that lion ain't very cowardly
all of a sudden I it's a whole different
um situation yeah that's wild man it's a
wild world out there it's the dark arts
you know and well what about the dark
web think about that oh I can't even
think about that yeah I can't even I
don't honey there yeah is there really a
dark web oh yeah yeah it exists and what
is you get into the back of your
computer's non monitored really and
there you know it's kind of the secret
world you need access and and it's like
the blockchain or something kind of like
in a way yeah exactly it's a good way to
put it and I don't I don't pretend to be
an expert no I've never been into it
it's it's it's something I'd like to
explore Wow
but it's a real thing it's a real thing
there's no
I know that because I know people who
are involved in investigating there that
makes me scared man yeah because the
Internet's already dark enough as it is
you know it makes me really really
scared
Oh take care of yourself
yeah happy holidays from us what do you
plan for Christmas Chris ah I'll be back
in Michigan and once I get things
wrapped up yeah as you know in this
business you know I'm trying to do a
month's worth of work in two weeks
yeah cuz after the 15th everything
pretty much shuts down to the first have
you ever been on dr. Drew's podcast Drew
Pinsky I have not I know a lot of people
who have had a love dinner you guys talk
I run in concentric circles you know a
lot of the dr. lisa strowman who's a
psychologist lawyer who's done some
stuff for our shows also there's a lot
of stuff that dr. drew so i mean you
know he's a smart guy with a good one
dr. Ahn's yeah yeah who's a sharp guy
and that's a that's an interesting show
to do but you have never done that I've
seen that guy at the gym once or twice
but but yeah dr. Drew's is fascinating
anyway after reach out to him and see if
um yes sometime when you're around if
you guys can be in the circle I would
just love to hear that conversation I
think it'd be really cool he's you know
he's a special guy a shortcut um and so
are you man Chris Hansen we appreciate
you I appreciate your time man thanks
for thank you so much and I look forward
to this on your future projects and
we'll promote them however we can help
bash it and you got a quick gift for
Chris oh yeah that's right if you go up
there with this from our sponsor this is
so nice oh that's great oh thank you so
it might be some guys after you holding
a graduate not today but just overall
you know yeah we're safe and it's even
hard to get into you almost need a knife
to get in to get into it yeah but um but
it is a nice blade menu and I think you
and I keep one in my car just in case
yeah um well that's nice how do you open
this yeah that's a good it's just a flap
on the front it's kind of tricky
it's like oh there you go yeah so there
you go but that yeah that's a nice
little piece and it I keep one in my car
though that's nice just to be safe
you know you you don't use one until you
need it and something's messed up or you
know were you trying to write yeah thank
you very much and break it out you know
no no I'm not saying lead with it years
ago as a kid a buddy of mine and I would
Tawana I mean 19 years old and of course
we bought you know switchblades it
stilettos I was digging through drawer I
don't know a couple years ago and I
found this thing it's too little but it
works and I keep it in the drawer in the
apartment because it works as a
screwdriver now if their letter opener
and that and my oldest Adi goes you know
euchre that on the street that'll get
your year and I don't take it out of the
apartment you're you get a year for that
I got and not in the apartment
unscrewing a you know a light fixture I
I am to be pretty familiar by the way
man I taught you everything you know not
serving it back shouldn't be a bad
increment Chris Hansen thank you so much
you yeah I remember to check my bag with
this so I don't get busted oh yeah
that's true that yeah we would love you
to have on so great thank you Chris
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]
[Music]